I'm not laughing at the guilt I feel
this I came from a home that was highly
money insecure it was a time it was
tough I still to this day
have to Exhale I walked around Guitar
Center the other night budgeting like
ready to rock and roll and I couldn't do
it I couldn't do it I couldn't do it
until finally I did it right it was
tough I had that guilt is real that is
not a downside to paying off my debt
that is a built-in
trauma response that I have that me and
a counselor need to work out I don't
need to counsel people and and tell them
hey
don't don't get peace in your life
because you're going to feel weird about
it I need to go deal with my personal
feelings and so if this is you if you've
paid off everything and you realize it
didn't solve all your childhood wounds
it won't yep you gotta go do that work